build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home some of the coolest creations
from everyday people this is be building
justin Beckerman is a high school
student that built his own submarine
that he actually uses he spent a month
designing it in five months building it
the body of the submarine is a drain
pipe it has a motor regulators and
valves from an old soda machine three
battery systems float sensors a horn a
CB radio to communicate with people on
the surface lights and a camera system
that allows him to send a signal to a TV
for others to see what he does and all
of this set him back around nine hundred
and fifty dollars
Rosanna pansino creates pop culture and
video game inspired cakes and cookies on
her show nerdy nummies her custom baked
good creations include Mario piranha
cookie pops creeper rice krispie treats
and even an Indiana Jones monkey brain
cake and for the last episode of bdp she
actually made some vsauce cupcakes Caleb
from hackaday created an 80,000 volt
homemade Thor hammer the head of the
hammer is made from foam and the handle
is PVC wrapped in leather with the
battery located in the bottom of the
handle and the core of the hammer
there's a built-in Tesla coil that's
able to power light bulbs and shock
metal pieces check out his channel for
more hats
Tom Eckert makes extremely lifelike
sculptures out of wood some of his most
impressive work includes flowing forms
like that of fabric that look as though
they're translucent he uses traditional
woodworking techniques to create the
pieces and then paints them with a
waterborne lacquer that he applies with
both an airbrush and brushes and he says
that his preferred woods are basswood
Linden and lime wood because they're
stable and carve well draw Kirsten of
Chicago created this delightful series
of illustrations of what famous TV and
movie characters do on their days off
they include alien takes Jonesy to the
vet
Michael irons the jumpsuit and the twin
peaks' homage bedtime for log la base de
louvre ICI created these nightmare
pop-culture character illustrations
including Donald Duck Yoshi and this one
called nightmare
been where he says the idea here is that
finn devoured jake consuming his
abilities and thus turning into this
huge creep and now for some retro video
game themed art from the IM 8-bit
entertainment system art show
8-bit ego has an awesome series called
pixel vision where Josh and Massoud take
turns creating video game character
artwork including sack boy and bison and
Donkey Kong flying this 22,000 pound
soil compactor was converted into a huge
music box that plays the star-spangled
banner by artist David Cole
Jimmy de Resta a guitar designer turns
in ak-47 into a functional guitar for
Wyclef Jean
here's the video for Sam West Valens
guitar percussion cover of Pantera's
mouth for war finally here's the video
for plastic and flashing lights by
Professor click with animation by Victor
Hagelin
submit your bidipis as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at facebook.com slash
Vsauce TW o
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bdp radio music created
and submitted by you guys also check out
your bidipi an entire video dedicated to
your creations and as always thanks for
watching